In CS:GO, there are good plays, there are
great plays, and then there are plays so memorable,
so iconic that Valve has chosen to immortalize
them in the very fabric of the game.
I’m Colin for theScore esports, and today
we’re taking a look at the incredible plays
behind CS:GO’s map graffiti and signs.
Now, for this installment of Best of, guys,
we chose to ignore Goose on Dust II and the
bird boost sign on Train.
While they do have their own cool stories
associated with them, they’re not backed
by the kind of incredible plays that we’re
looking for in this video.
(Gameplay)
Now let’s get things started with what is
perhaps the most iconic of the iconic graffiti
spray plays, Coldzera’s jumping AWP.
(Casting)
We were in the semi-finals of the world tournament.
It’s the biggest Counter-Strike tournament
there had ever been.
Ten-thousand fans at the first American major,
the crowd was so loud, there was screaming.
Luminosity was down to Team Liquid.
Everything looked like it was about to end.
Coldzera defied the game mechanics by jumping
and taking a shot, killing not only one of
his opponents, but two with one bullet.
If it wasn’t for that play I think we wouldn’t
win the Major.
(casting)
And then the defuse, to get round 15 in the
fire.
We should really rename this map to Olof-pass,
right?
We are always talking about ninja defuses
in the smokes now, right, and now there is
a whole new meta like ‘ I’ll just stand
in the flames it doesn’t matter, man.’
Someone get this guy a firefighter suit, he
just went in the fire, burning man.
Wait, don’t give Valve any ideas.
(casting)
My favourite moment at the major is my double
no-scope.
I played for Team Liquid against Fnatic at
ESL One Cologne.
Every member of my team just was so happy.
Every crowd member, so happy.
It was first time that I did something insane
at the major.
In two months I did tattoo to remind me of
that moment.
Here is like angel with wings, here is like
his eye, no scope, and here is a bullet.
Those shots I will never forget in my life.
Now guys, not every incredible play does get it’s
own graffiti spray.
Some get a sign, like the clips in our next
section.
I am excited because I heard a rumor that
Fnatic have some crazy stuff planned on this
map.
(casting)
To try and surprise LDLC.
We don’t even know what it is, so.
(casting)
It doesn’t tell us that much, but they were
being secretive about it and I don’t blame
them.
Something like this had never really been
seen before in a long time of Counter-Strike,
even dating to previous versions.
Things had to come together at the same time.
If that was the second map, we might still
be in the series and going to three maps,
you know?
All these unfortunate things had to come together,
together at the same time and at the worst
possible moment, because this was the time,
based on how it was going, they were going
to beat Fnatic.
(casting)
So NiP they…..
Can I ask for some bananas in here as well?
I don’t see why not.
If you need bananas Friberg, bananas you will
get.
(casting)
Can I ask for some bananas in here as well?
Now, Valve removed this next grafitti when
Dust II was overhauled.
But that doesn’t mean the play behind it
isn’t still worth remembering.
(casting)
Well guys that’s I’ve got for you this
week.
If you’ve got an incredible play in mind
that you think Valve should immortalize in
a spray or a sign, let me know in the comments
below and I will see you next week.